You can't develop a perfect system.
Somebody's gonna fall through the
street,
through the cracks,
but they fall through the cracks in
Europe and Canada
below it.
I'm just saying this,
I like our system of innovation.
I like to fight who mapped the human
genome we did in America,
uh,
who's the one that discovered,
you know,
all the vast majority of new drugs in
the last five years that are so helpful
to curing illnesses,
Americans,
American research labs and American
companies.
A lot of the research companies are
coming to America because we do have a
cost structure that allow a company to
recoup their investment of their
research when it costs to take a drug
from the laboratory to the bedside.
And this is very important.
And,
uh,
I don't think you will find that kind of
support and they in a European system.
And that's why I think it's so important
for us to keep our,
our own competitive system.